DEREK DOWNEY: Hi.
I'm Derek Downey, a developer
advocate for Google Cloud.
I am currently working
on developing a banking
application that leverages Cloud
Spanner, the highly-scalable,
managed relational
database from Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the previous video, I set
up a regional Spanner instance
with a small amount
of compute capacity
for developing my
banking application.
I also created a customers
database on the instance.
And all the tables related to my
app will live in this database.
Now, my company might have other
internal-only data completely
unrelated to my banking app.
That data could be placed
in a separate database,
because Spanner instances
can have multiple databases.
Databases are a way to organize
related tables together
and to provide additional access
control to the data stored
on the instance.
For example, my banking
app should definitely not
have access to the
internal database.
Besides access
control, each database
can be configured with
different options that
affect the
performance, recovery,
and security of your database.
These options control
the optimizer version,
version retention period,
and database encryption.
The first database option
is the optimizer version.
The optimizer's job is to
create an execution plan that
is an efficient way to retrieve
data from Spanner based
on the given SQL query.
It has a direct impact on
performance of requests
issued to your database.
Over time, the
query optimizer will
change to improve the accuracy
of the estimates required
to create this execution plan.
When Spanner releases a
new optimizer version,
the default behavior
is for databases
to use the new version
30 days after release.
Optimizer versions can
change the performance
of your query workload.
So it's important to
compare query performance
of the new version
with the older version.
You can pin the
optimizer version
a database uses to
a specific version
by altering the database.
Altering the database
optimizer version to null
resets to the default
behavior of updating
30 days after the
release of a new version.
You can also change
the optimizer version
for individual queries by
providing the optimizer version
query hunt.
This is useful to
validate queries
where stable performance is
critical without changing
the optimizer version
for the entire database.
Another important
database option
is the version
retention period, which
affects the ability to perform
a point in time recovery.
By default, Spanner
will maintain
all versions of the data
and schema for one hour.
In my banking
application, I want
to protect against
accidental data loss.
With Spanner's
default retention,
I have an hour to copy
the data as it existed
before an accidental
change and then
load it back into the database.
During normal
business operations,
this hour might be enough.
But what about during
off hours or the weekend?
I might not be able to respond
in time to avoid data loss.
So I want to be sure to
size my version retention
period to give my team enough
time to recover outside
of normal hours.
One way to do this would be
to set the version retention
period according to
my backup frequency.
For instance, if I take a backup
of my database once a day, then
I will want to set my version
retention period to one day.
The last option I will
cover is how encryption is
handled for Spanner databases.
All data in Spanner
is encrypted at rest.
By default, this encryption
is handled for you
by Google Cloud.
However, if you have
specific compliance
or regulatory requirements on
the keys encrypting the data,
Spanner offers the ability
to deploy your own encryption
keys.
These are called Customer
Managed Encryption Keys,
and are managed through
Google Cloud KMS.
It is possible to have
some databases configured
with customer encryption
keys, while other databases
on the same instance use Google
Cloud to manage encryption.
Setting up and
managing these custom
encryption keys is beyond
the scope of this video.
But there are some important
pieces of information
when using custom
encryption keys.
First, a database
must be created
with the custom encryption key.
Custom encryption keys cannot
be enabled on an existing
database.
Second, for backups,
the primary version
of the encryption key at
the time of backup creation
is used to encrypt backups.
Finally, encryption keys
must be available to decrypt
the database and backups.
If a key is deleted
and can't be recovered,
any Spanner database or
backup encrypted with that key
is unrecoverable.
For now, I will be using the
default encryption managed
by Google Cloud for my
banking application.
Cloud Spanner offers the
ability to organize related data
into multiple databases
on your Spanner instance.
This provides some
additional control
over who has access to
the data stored there.
In this video, I went
over some other options
that give you more control
over the performance, recovery,
and security of your
Spanner database.
In our next video, I
will go into more detail
about the Spanner
schema, including
data types, data organization,
and schema management.
In the meantime, please
let us know in the comments
if you have any questions
around database specific options
in Spanner.
[MUSIC PLAYING]